so our different kinds of monsters like
different races or they like completely
different species you've got different
numbering advice some with wings just
want to know what the rules are you
frighten Elementary is one of presumably
many shameless scare poems that we will
see throughout the film but all of the
other strange powers that these monster
children probably have ie laser vision
spitting acid mucus this guy who seems
like his mere existence as a hazard are
totally okay are we missing
quirky protagonists got left behind
creating a significant reveal cliche the
seme pocket like a kangaroo because no
one here is wearing any clothes again
not sure of the genetics going on here
it's for a dominant or recessive trait
we're entering a very dangerous area
which is apparently okay to bring a
school group of children to this is
where we collect the scream energy to
power our whole world between this movie
and the other monsters movie there's
never been a clear explanation as to how
its collected are they just collecting
sound why does human scream produce this
energy and not monster scream this all
seems very complicated when they could
just capture a bunch of human children
and make them scream for a while into a
large machine
oh wait that's the plot of the other
movie carry on the right stuff style
heroes walk cliche which also appeared
in Monsters Inc if you rip off your own
rip off does that make it new I learned
everything I know from my school
monsters University roll credits it's
the best scaring school there is you
wish via text let's these colleges are
also vaguely named our big diploma Mills
I guess it kind of sucks that he can't
see what's going on
but all he's missing is a monster
walking through a door something he
probably sees every day what happened to
the buddy system maybe the teacher
should let the pair's take turns seeing
what happens instead of letting the
crowd around a dangerous entryway Mike
knows not to go over the line because
they set it like four times in the last
three minutes so if he's clearly going
to break the rules why would he not try
to sort of hi also this teacher is a
really incompetent buddy I heard
something that dad didn't look around
them for two more seconds and say I
don't remember barring our son a blue
alligator skin jacket so after the
monster collects the scream he just
casually walks out of the room through
the closet and no kid in the history of
scream collecting has found this to be
weird
there are trading cards for the best
scarers who are essentially a factory
workers this monster society is pretty
big on communist propaganda
also since the scaring isn't televised
how are these guys big stars with
trading cards
everything looks just like it does in
our world but has little spikes on it
because you know monsters
I'm welling up with tears the bus driver
is able to pronounce her s sounds really
well given her jaw and teeth situation
what are the suitcases carrying it's
well-established that no one in this
world wears clothes except for an
occasional shirt hat or jacket which
brings up this question does everyone
just walking around completely naked and
if so could they not have genitals if
they did this would be a very different
movie universities of our world would
kill for this kind of diversity imagine
the pamphlets who was that monster
throwing that giant frisbee - was it the
one other 50-foot monster in the school
if so I'm glad they like each other they
would be very difficult to avoid also
how many items are scaled up for the
giant monsters she certainly can't
attend any classes and buildings or sit
in chairs also I know this is a universe
filled with monsters but this is the
only giant we've seen between both of
the films Pixar's made about the monster
world I would think that the 50-foot
monster would be viewed as a freak and
would have a very difficult life because
they couldn't fit anywhere this is the
real story here it looks like they're
just making normal doors how do they
know where the doors are supposed to
look like to match up with the closet
door in the human world is it the door
that's special or the apparatus that
holds the door that's la missing here if
they eat the trash then why did they
have trash cans it would probably be
more efficient to just take what you
weren't going to eat back up to the
buffet counter and avoid the trashcan
altogether it seems like your physical
appearance is indicative of what social
club you should join which is something
that their universe and our universe
have in common that's racist the things
humans have that allow them to
comfortably wear glasses do not apply to
Randi and many other monsters that we
will see later
yet his glasses are staying up no
trouble yeah but lose the glasses they
give it away and that's how Randy got
his devious quit by forgoing vision
correction how many college age kids
still have retainers that they need to
wear all the time I guess this is an
effort to make him look younger and
dorky but I've seen several other
monsters that have a greater need for an
orthodontist like this guy any monsters
University way too much like regular
human college and not the backdrop of a
Nightmare Before Christmas fail that
exam and you are out of the scaring
program I'm not sure why the monsters
seemed shocked at this this is a society
that's huge on bureaucracy and this is a
venerated program in a famous
institution this pass/fail requirement
should be common knowledge among
students Dean hardscrabble is one of the
few monsters that gets to wear clothes
Sullivan like Bill Sullivan the scarer
yeah he's my dad
Sullivan is a very common name this was
a roll of the dice this is like a
student waltzing in named Jones and the
professor says like Tommy Lee Jones the
actor and that being right I'm sorry
should I keep going on uh mr. Sullivan's
coveted all Sully did was roar he didn't
answer the professor's question my
theory is that the professor has a
monster equivalent of a hard-on for
Sully this monster explicitly called a
pig isn't much bigger than Mike and
appears to not be answered for more so
they could theoretically like eat it
what are the rules Sully and Mike's
first encounter and subsequent rivalry
occur because somehow a pig Sully stole
from fear Tech managed to climb into
Mike's dorm room which is an impossible
height for pigs or Sully is this pig
also half spider or can pigs just run up
walls in his universal it is convenient
that the big spider took Mike to the
place they were just discussing minutes
earlier where he didn't want to go just
in case you didn't get that Randy was
lame the animators of this film used his
cupcakes against him by writing lame
across his face for the record I would
probably hang out with the guy at the
party who had the cupcakes I blow of
cupcakes Mike makes a decision to make
an impossible shot that would in no way
work in a real-world situation you might
be saying to yourself well this is a
college filled with monsters this isn't
the real world but the physical
properties of things are the same there
as they are here so the sin still stands
thus ending an argument I just had with
myself now that the pig spider has
caught the trash can he is making no
further efforts to get away even though
he easily could that guy just happens to
have a monster do you sticker with him
I'm glad he found a place for it also is
the logo for the school the same as the
logo for the Monsters Inc Energy Company
there's no indication that the energy
company owns the school also we met a
graduate from fear Tech working on the
scare floor at monsters Inc we either
have some vertical integration going on
here or some serious copyright
infringement this round one-eyed guy is
the only character we've met so far that
has a voice that matches the shape of
his mouth even Johnny here shouldn't be
able to speak so smooth with that
underbite blowed out squirt I really
don't think that this guy can call Mike
squirt they are the same size is it
their version of beer pong get the
gooiest guy wasted so that we can play
tic-tac-toe on his chest with our ping
pong balls that seems a lot more
complicated and difficult than the way
we do it apparently the only way to get
on the monsters you or fear tech
football team is to be purple or orange
respectively
now that's racist where did this guy
come from I feel like I would have
noticed him at the line of scrimmage
also having a giant blob on your
football team that is impossible to take
down is colossal e unfair the story just
glazes over how Mike loses his job after
injuring several students dominant
silverback gorilla how do they know what
silverback gorillas are do they have
silverback gorillas in the monster world
one frightening face does not a scare a
make isn't this entire course and
scaring basically just an acting class
if that was so important why was it not
bolted down
or better yet why
was it even there at all they were
college freshmen in their everyday
goofing around near Darien secured
artifacts this is more Dean hardscrabble
fault than Mike and Sully's door aw
wouldn't make him scream it would make
him cry alerting his parents exposing
the monster world destroying life as we
know it as the monster world which is
full of modern day technology always had
this ability to jump into the human
world for power or was there a monster
version of prehistoric times
a monster industrial revolution scaring
classes and more history classes please
all so how does it get crying and danger
their operation over a kid screaming
this seems like the monster could easily
run away before the parents got there
well unless crime makes parents
instantly appear like genies afterwards
what you lack is something that cannot
be taught you're not scary granted she
is just saying what someone should have
said to Mike long ago but her
inspiration seems to be just because
they broke her scare canister the
inspiration is further supported by the
fact that she had to have let him into
the school in the first place she's the
theme this is a flagship competition for
this school if they couldn't splurge on
a better painter I bet foghorn leghorn
just forgot to get one and improvise but
if you lose you will leave monsters
University I know Dean hardscrabble is a
total hard-ass but monster society is
extremely civilized seems like this
wager would run afoul of bylaws and
ethics committees 30 years in the
textile industry and then old dandy Don
got downsized figured I could throw
myself a pity party or go back to school
and learn the computers this is too real
painfully real it's too real of sin for
a cartoon monster movie shouldn't a
monster universe have a human creature
on there Lisa Frank style notebooks a
unicorn Griffin thing probably lives out
there somewhere basically you guys have
no scaring experience not sure why Sully
asks this question with the cadence of
surprise based on the look of these guys
he should have known that they have no
scaring experience you're about the
scariest fella I've ever seen even with
them pink polka dots I'm afraid Don is
colorblind those are purple polka dots
is that an anarchy symbol in the middle
of skater what does Pixar trying to
promote we know this isn't true because
of the other movie but if everyone
believes this how are any of the
monsters able to move around these kids
rooms without freaking out they clearly
touch things in the room that the kid is
touched because we have everything we
need to win right here
heart way where's Mike's heart he's 80
percent mouth there are so many toxic
spiky balls in this race there's no way
any team could possibly navigate it
cleanly yet for the most part this
happens I'm gonna beat you over that
finish line you're ready by dust some
might think that in a team race it's
best they raced each other instead I
don't care what universe you're in if
someone found out that the Dean of a
university was condoning events where
the students were being exposed to toxic
material the Dean would be forced to
resign and the fraternities involved the
most likely be disbanded I find it
totally ridiculous that know-it-all Mike
thinks that just because he and Sully
crossed the finish line went off the
rest of the team they finished the race
I would check the other teams for
protective gel also I'm having trouble
believing that only who's ma Kappa
members were the only ones that ran into
the spiky balls also if you're a frat
why would you cheat when you have the
front that is so obviously bad that
they're gonna lose all you have to do is
not come in last there are no points for
first Oh for those of you keeping score
at home they have silverback gorillas
and normal ladybugs in their universe
the faculty at this school can get away
with literally anything the noise he
made was completely out of his control
yet it got him physically ejected from
the building by being thrown through the
roof also this monster remains
completely unharmed even after being
thrown through the roof of that
four-story building and hitting a tree
not getting caught is loosely defined
here I would think that doing something
to make the librarian aware of your
presence would be getting caught since
it's important for the parents did not
believe there is actually a monster
living in the closet they shouldn't even
want them to be made aware of their
presence but that would allow our team
of ragtag monsters to win this challenge
sauce ending the movie this librarian
has a very severe case of a TD the
librarian is now making more noise and
causing more distracting damage than
anyone else in a library ever has and
she's not throwing herself out through
the roof you should have stuck to my
strategy Mike thinks his strategy was
working even though they were on the
cusp of losing because of his strategy
the girls from the pnk sorority all look
exactly the same when all the other
monsters look extremely different from
each other are they all sisters or just
extremely selective or perhaps racist
they were able to precisely dump each
color on each guy without getting any
mixed oper slightly missing did that
substance that they dumped on them make
them all stand and those cutesy
embarrassing poses or is that Polaroid
camera able to change someone's stance
because they clearly went out standing
that way when the pic
sticker does the school have no law
enforcement for disciplinary entity at
all because I'm sure this would fall
only extreme vandalism category yeah
where are we did no one else know where
they were going they only seem to have
just found out where they are no one
thought to ask Mike where they were
going this whole walk over and now Pixar
is going to teach your kids that
breaking and entering is okay this is an
extremely complex facility that Mike
only visited once when he was a small
child yet he knows exactly where to go
one would think that the only company
that provides energy for the monster
world would have better security
possibly security at its perimeter which
was easily breached by these college
students it looks like all the security
guards were just in the middle of the
facility making it easy for them to
break in and to escape how many times
the monsters walk through a kid's door
and there are teenagers lurking behind
it doing stupid light talking on the
phone and rebelling against their
parents this sorority which has been
very skilled up until this point is
arbitrarily thwarted by this avoid that
teenager challenge
we only saw three of the P NK girls get
trapped yet suddenly all six of them are
in the trapped area of this maze Randy
has an unfair advantage in the
heightened snake challenge because he
can just turn himself invisible
there really is no need for him to even
hide in the lamp apparently you only get
caught in this game if you're just so
shitty at hiding it looks like you're
not even trying because everyone knows
what Sulley looks like and him lying on
the ground like a bear rug should not be
a good hiding place but it did require a
small amount of effort tomorrow each of
you must prove that you are undeniably
scary and I know for a fact that one of
you is not just one I feel like
excluding Sulley Mike is the scariest of
all the oozma Kappa members there's no
reason for her to single Mike out when
all the rest of them are not scared if
they did the heightened sneak challenge
on this field Mike would clearly have
the advantage because he in the grass or
the exact same color they are running to
the scare simulators when that clearly
isn't necessary because this competition
is not a race
this guy's scared clearly not as good as
Sully's where his roar shook the other
room gives him a higher score for some
arbitrary reason I know everyone likes a
good underdog but why is no one
suspicious that Mike got a perfect score
everyone just seemed to accept that Mike
was able to beat everyone else's score
including Sully's no one is suspicious
that maybe someone tampered with this
machine why would you ever have settings
like this a scare is a scare those who
among these students pursuing a degree
benefits from the easy setting also why
does the bed have settings for six
different scares instead of just one
uniform setting for everybody what was I
supposed to do let the whole team fail
because you don't have it I'm still not
with them on the mike has no potential
to be scary thing no one seemed to be
saying that for any of the other members
of Oz macap but they all seemed to have
equal scariness - Mike the
relationship between the monsters world
and the humans world is so volatile why
would a student's ID allow Mike to
access the land and operation of a door
maybe I was just jumpy as a kid but even
if I saw a little green one-eyed thing
in the middle of the night I wouldn't
want to approach it even if it sounded
like Billy Crystal because you were born
a Sullivan Sullivan
I'm the Sullivan who flunked every test
the humans are hunting you but let's
stand in the open air and yell at each
other
Mike's extremely muddy feet are now
magically clean but most of the time I'm
terrified how come you never told me
that before we weren't friends before
they weren't friends after the exchange
at Monsters Inc this question is not
Mike's follow-up question
they forgot for a moment that they were
being chased my toxic humans in the
human world it is not standard operating
procedure to chase after a bear with
nothing but flashlights and
righteousness there are adults I can't
do this were they told that adults
couldn't be scared by monsters I know a
lot of adults and most of them would be
poop their pants scared if a slowly like
monster came out of nowhere and roared
at them maybe the monster studied the
energy capabilities of pants pooping why
the flashlights again that's probably a
light switch inside the cabin do
microcell we have telekinetic powers how
are they able to get the fan to move in
the window to open from the ceiling also
a bunch of other things are gonna happen
that they have no way of actually
controlling without some sort of
supernatural power if the canisters can
be filled without being attached to the
door is attaching them really necessary
also it seems like adult screens are
more powerful than kids screams why did
this moment not teach them that scaring
adults is more effective art scrabbles
letting us into the scare program hearts
rebel showed no mercy to Mike and Sulley
they were able to power a door from the
other side which is apparently something
no one has done before but she gives the
rest of Lou's macap a chance to be in
the scare program because they were kind
of scary come on Tom there has to be a
monster Kinkos for you to make new
business cards it should just be like a
regular Kinkos but with spikes on it
you're the scariest bunch of monsters I
have ever met don't let anyone tell you
different and since they didn't show up
in monsters Inc that's the last time
Mike and Sulley ever saw these friends
just like real college a red curb I
wonder how many meetings Pixar had to
have about what the parking laws are
here in monster world
Sulley was able to run and catch up with
the boss that was an impossible distance
away from him
careful mr. Sullivan I was just warming
up to you
does warming up to him include expelling
him from school monsters and hires two
monsters recently expelled from school
Oh have you no tampered with the mail is
a crime punishable by banishment lazily
tossing in a reason for the abominable
snowman management monsters Inc the only
company with internal upward mobility
spider pig spider pig does whatever a
spider pig choice
you are the lowest form of life on earth
you're not even human fucking big killer
nothing but on the organize grab a stick
pieces of amphibians
what's keeping you here get up along
here why don't you just good cause I got
no place else to go
one big damn conspiracy and everyone's
in on it
if crunchyroll offered sushi and not
anime they would deliver the largest
most diverse selection of professionally
subtitled sushi with no ads and you'll
only have to wait one hour to get it
Brett from Japan
that's because crunchyroll is an anime
streaming service that offers the
largest most diverse collection of
professionally subtitled anime series
and crunchyroll premium lets you watch
them all in HD with no ads crunchy
volcanium also gets you new frames as
soon as your hour after they air in
Japan with subtitles the best part you
can enjoy it all free for 30 days when
you go to crunchyroll.com slash
cinemasins
yes that's a month of unlimited
professionally subtitled anime manga and
drama titles that you can enjoy on all
of your devices all you have to do is
click the link in the description or
head to crunchyroll.com slash citizens
to get started